على اعلى المستويات اذا راويه تستمر
تحقيقات في الولايات المتحده للتحقق من
عشرات الوثائق الامنيه التي سربت من
البانتاجون وانتشرت على مواقع التواصل
والوصول الى الجهه التي سربت الوثائق
مسؤولون امريكيون وخبراء امن غربيون قالوا
انهم يشتبهون في ان شخصا من الولايات
المتحده قد يكون وراء التسريب واضاف
المسؤولون ان اتساع نطاق الموضوعات التي
تناولتها الوثائق من اوكرانيا الى الصين
واسرائيل وافريقيا تشير الى انه تم
تسريبها من احد المواطنين الامريكيين مصدر
مطلع على التحقيقات افاد بان تلك
المستندات الموسومه بالسريه والسريه
للغايه احيانا طويت على عجل واخفيت بشكل
امن لاخراجها وانتشرت تلك الوثائق على
الانترنت الشهر الماضي على منصه التواصل
الاجتماعي
بعض الوثائق في اطار التحقيقات ايضا
مسؤول امني ان هيئه الاركان المشتركه في
البانتاجون تدرس قوائم توزيع الخاصه بها
لمعرفه من يحصل عاده على مثل هذه التقارير
خاصه بعد ان حملت او حملت بعض الوثائق
المسربه بعدما حملت بعض هذه الوثائق
المسربه اذا علامات من استخبارات هيئه
الاركان المشتركه كانت الوثائق كما تبعنا
سابقا اظهرت تجسس الولايات المتحده على
خصومها وحتى على حلفائها ومن ضمنهم
اوكرانيا واسرائيل تحدثنا ايضا عن كوريا
الجنوبيه بالامس وعلى الرغم من ان التجسس
جزء لا مفر منه في عالم المخابرات الدوليه
الا ان دبلوماسيين من بعض دول المذكوره
قالوا ان الكشف عن الوثائق ربما يضر بسمعه
الولايات المتحده وينعكس سلبا عليها
[موسيقى]
تسريب الوثائق هذه ينظر اليه على انه من
اخطر الخروقات الامنيه منذ تسريبات
ويكيليكس كما تذكرون عام 2013 بعض الجهات
وصفت تسريب الاخير بالاسوا والاكثر ضررا
خاصه وان عمر بعض الوثائق التي كشف عنها
لم يتجاوز اربعين يوما مسؤولون امريكيون
قالوا ان التحقيق في مراحله الاولى مع عدم
استبعاد احتماليه ان تكون عناصر مؤيده
لروسيا وراء التسريب اشار المسؤولون الى
ان بعض الوثائق اشارت بتفاصيل دقيقه الى
نقاط ضعف الجيش الاوكراني كما اوضحت اخرى
كيف سيتم استنفاذ انظمه الدفاع الجوي
الاوكرانيه الثلاثمائه بحلول الثاني من
مايو المقبل وفقا لمعدل استخدامها الحالي
اذا المعلومات كلها تؤثر على الوضع
الميداني الان حتى خبراء عسكريون قالوا ان
مثل هذه المعلومات ذات فائده كبيره للقوات
الروسيه خاصه بعد الكشف عن خطه عسكريه
اوكرانيه ما دفع كييف لتعديل او تغيير بعض
الخطط
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات